Narrator: There's a cool thing happening
in this scene in Jordan Peele's "Nope."
You may notice it starts out pretty dark,
then slowly gets brighter.
Here, you can't see the logo on OJ's hat,
but two minutes later in a
nearly identical shot, you can.
It's an incredibly subtle trick
that cinematographer Hoyte
Van Hoytema used to emulate
how our eyes naturally
respond to darkness.
We build up sort of
fades-in that are very slow
but that simulate very
much your pupil dilations.
Narrator: But what makes
this subtle trick possible
is that this nighttime scene
was shot in the daytime.
Day for night is a technique
Hollywood has used for years,
but it hasn't always
produced convincing results
or clearly visible ones, as seen in shows
like "House of the Dragon."
So, how did Hollywood get to this point?
Here you might be wondering:
Why wouldn't filmmakers
just film their nighttime scenes at night?
[chuckles]
And in reality, many do,
taking advantage of artificial lighting
and today's more sensitive
digital camera sensors.
But neither modern digital camera sensors
nor traditional film have the sensitivity
of the human eye in low-light scenarios.
That means that often, when night scenes
are filmed in natural lighting conditions,
very little of the shot is visible.
This is why Hollywood often films
what's called day for night,
shooting nighttime scenes in daylight
and using cinematic techniques
to create the illusion of darkness.
François Truffaut even paid
homage to the technique
in a movie called "Day for Night."
One standard way to shoot day for night
is by filming against a blue screen
and creating a totally CG environment.
But many filmmakers, like
Jordan Peele on "Nope,"
want the grounded reality of shooting
as much as possible out in the field.
When shooting on location,
traditional day-for-night techniques
typically involve manipulating
the color grading,
adding a bluish tint, and
upping the contrast on the image
until it resembles night,
or using smoke, dust, or sand
and creating fake silhouettes.
The most famous examples
of these techniques
all shared a similar challenge as "Nope":
filming on location in
vast desert landscapes,
capturing expanses of
land and sky that are just
too big to light when filming at night.
But the combination of these techniques
can create a slightly artificial look,
one that Jordan and Hoyte
referred to as "movie nights."
They noticed the movie-nights aesthetic
in their visual references for "Nope,"
including older Westerns
and the 1962 film "Lawrence of Arabia."
There's big day-for-night sequences
in "Lawrence of Arabia,"
and as great and as grand --
it's people on camels and
wide, vast landscapes --
and we realized very quickly
that we wanted that scope,
but we didn't want that look.
Narrator: But to go beyond
the limited aesthetic
of traditional day-for-night filming,
they'd have to get much
more technical and creative.
Their goal was to capture the way
the human eye sees at night,
not the way a camera sees,
like the way our eyes
gradually adjust to darkness.
Stare at this dark shape --
or, for that matter, just imagine it.
Turns out, just thinking about dark spaces
can start to dilate our pupils
so that we can take in
more visual information.
Like "Nope," "Mad Max: Fury
Road" emulated this transition
subtly by starting its
night scene out pretty dark
to sell the night, then
slowly making it brighter.
Once our eyes are adjusted,
there's the question of how to replicate
the level of fine detail that
we can perceive at night.
Productions often struggle
to nail this down,
especially because when
filming day for night,
DPs usually underexpose the
scenes by three or four stops,
planning to make them as dark as possible.
However, underexposed day-for-night scenes
are often rendered so dark
to compensate for the daytime
that you can barely make
out anything at all.
Audiences have complained
about this limited visibility
in modern TV shows like
"House of the Dragon,"
which was shot in full day
and then darkened -- a lot -- in post.
Selective use of light
can help make scenes
more legible to viewers.
In "Pan's Labyrinth," DP Guillermo Navarro
was going for an eerie effect,
so he drilled tiny holes in the sets
to allow some light to leak in.
In the giant-frog scene,
he lit Ofelia's face
with a fiber-optic light
attached directly to the camera.
Other films have gone
the opposite direction.
"Mad Max" wanted viewers to
be able to follow every shot
of its big nighttime set piece,
so the team massively
overexposed the photography
to ensure they captured all
the detail in the shadows.
The effect worked well on "Mad Max"
because of the dynamic range
of the digital cameras used on the film
and because of the stylized night look
that they were going for,
which was supposed to look realistic
but not photorealistic,
so they could afford to make
it less dark and more blue.
"Mad Max" also used a
lot of sky replacements.
And skies are in fact
often the biggest giveaways
when filming day for night.
When a scene's darkened in post,
the skies often still look bright
relative to the rest of the shot,
so we can feel the day leak through.
To create authentic night skies on "Nope,"
Hoyte pulled from earlier
work on "Ad Astra,"
where he had experimented
with infrared cameras
to create the black skies
of the moon chase sequence.
Hoyte: There's very little
ambient light on the moon,
so it's a very weird
hybrid of day and night.
We needed to shoot a rover
chase on the moon's surface,
which is a gigantic area,
something we couldn't light up.
So you end up with a black-and-white image
that has very good light levels
and a light relationship
between lightness and darkness.
But then you have to figure
out a way to get color back,
and you could think about
coloring it by hand,
but we were thinking, "Well,
we are shooting this on film.
What if we could combine
those two cameras together
and then just mix the color back in
selectively where we want it?"
You use one camera to
tell you the relationship
of the light levels between everything,
and then you use the other camera
to gather color information
and film grain and such things.
Narrator: By shooting natural
sunlight with infrared cameras
and then giving it a
slight contrast boost,
you end up with images
that are brightly lit
but with dark skies,
which worked perfectly for "Nope."
Let's go, boy!
Yeah!
Narrator: But this time, Hoyte
had to restructure the rig
for the super-heavy large-format cameras
that he and Jordan were working with.
Hoyte: So we ramped it up
because this one we shot
on 65-millimeter film, so we had to
rebuild the rig for a
65-millimeter-film camera.
Narrator: While the cameras
were ready to shoot,
the rig was heavy and pretty unbalanced.
And a lot of the night sequences in "Nope"
were major action set pieces,
where the crew had to follow
running horses and actors
and couldn't be limited
in how they could move the rig around.
So they stabilized the rig
by attaching it to a specially
retrofitted camera car.
Hoyte: A lot of the action
that we shot over the field,
we shot from an instrument
called the Edge.
It's a car with an arm,
which has a very big
stabilized head on there.
Narrator: The rig also allowed
for a more dynamic shoot
by addressing one of the limitations
of traditional day for night:
needing the sun exactly in
the right place when filming.
Typically, depending on the time of day,
the sun can cast harsh,
overly dramatic shadows
that filmmakers want to avoid.
If you do traditional day for night,
the quality of the image
is so dependent on your light direction.
Day for night works very
nice if you're backlit.
It works not very well if you're frontlit.
Narrator: Typically,
filmmakers get around this
by carefully positioning the actors
with their backs to the sun
to create a rim-light effect
that resembles moonlight.
Hoyte: With the infrared rig,
we found that it was much easier.
We didn't have to be as
precious about light direction
as you traditionally need
to be for day for night.
Narrator: In post, the VFX team merged
the digital infrared footage
with the color film footage
in a process that almost resembles
colorizing an old black-and-white movie,
except instead of inventing the colors,
they could extract them from
the film-camera photography,
which captured all the vital
color and texture information.
Run, OJ! Run!
Narrator: This allowed
the filmmakers on "Nope"
to capture more detail --
important for how Jordan
wanted the audience to
experience the movie.
Instead of pushing the
thriller forward by relying
on the blunt force of the
dark night and sound effects,
he wanted to encourage the audience
to actively look into the darkness
and start seeing things for themselves.
Hoyte: Traditionally,
cinematographers hide things
in the shadow, and there's darkness,
but you see just what the
cinematographer needs you to see.
But here, we wanted, at
first, to put you at a place
[rumbling]
and give you that scope,
and then within that,
sort of play with these little elements.
[rumbling]
Yeah, nah, nah, nah.
Narrator: Combining the
color with the infrared
also helped the team nail
the correct relationships
between light and dark parts of each shot.
We were, of course, being very analytical
about how your eye perceives
different colors at night.
The way that, for
instance, foliage and green
is much brighter at night
than a lot of other colors.
The fact that the light on ground level
is very often brighter than
what you get from the sky.
The sky plays a very big role in "Nope,"
so we also want to be able to feel the sky
and feel the differences in density
in where there's overcast,
where there's clouds,
or where there's moonlight,
et cetera, et cetera.
Narrator: In post, the team
sprinkled in additional details
to emphasize the full richness
and depth of the night scenes.
Hoyte: Visual effects went back at night,
shot very specific plates
of practical lights
in the distance to then
add it to those pictures.
And for me, these little things are really
the cherry toppings on the cake.
It totally completes it
and sort of finishes it.
Looking up at the mountain ridge,
there's these telegraph poles,
and they have these tiny little
red blinking lights on them.
And in your monochromatic view of night,
you see those little red dots blinking,
and suddenly, you're looking at a picture
that has full saturation
to it and full depth.
Narrator: But one last piece was missing.
Hoyte: This is shot in California,
and you get very little clouds.
The story of "Nope" is a very
specific cat-and-mouse game
in which Jean Jacket is hiding in clouds
and moving from one cloud to the other.
Narrator: So the VFX team
added digital cloudscapes
created from modular sets of
hundreds of 3D-modeled clouds,
altered to match the light
of the combined infrared-color footage.
The VFX team also added
drifting shadows of the clouds
to connect the sky with the ground.
And in "Nope," this tech
and partnership between
camera and visual effects
made the movie nights feel every bit
as real, immersive, and expansive
as how Jordan and Hoyte
experienced them on location.